anna eddy mitchell bonsoir quand tu fais
la pub pour machines à laver l'affront
42 fois où c'est normal ah non j'ai non
seulement par an et en plus je passais
genre vous empruntez le problème était
ce que grâce à la pub
monsieur faire des cadeaux qu'on m'a
jamais offert au cinéma pourtant je fais
pas mal de fil à des biens donnés en
gouaille et j'entends encore discrète
mais j'ai jamais eu des moyens comme
j'ai eu sur la pub stage parle pas en
tant que bons eddy mitchell qu'ils ont
faim qui proposera un produit eddy
mitchell réalisateur et acteur bon j'ai
obtenu des crédits que n'aura jamais sur
un fait j'ai obtenu une équipe technique
que j'aurais dû pouvoir en train de
dormir soit une machine à laver
formation de fureur cette série à
avant cette paix paraissent ici si ça
peut me faire rire non m objet de
respect non mais non je vais en moi ça
me fait rire puisque c'est du pacs ne
contre + point là c'est bon ça c'est de
la pub terre qui nous soit dit mitchell
ou quelqu'un d'autre
c'est un personnage public sourit de son
image par rapport à une image que plus
forte que la sienne r
je parle sur un mégot arrive à remplacer
la mère denis tu sais pas on peut pas
remplacer la mère de venir en plastoc
autant dire sale nom m'a rien dit du
tout aulas alors on en a rien n'a bougé
c'est tu paye beaucoup d'impôt maximum
d'impôt est par contre ce qui te fait
chier une faute à payer des impôts c'est
qu'on vient de te re taper sur un peu de
charité business c'est un truc qui te
dit tu as toujours gonflées bien tu dis
aujourd'hui l'ethiopie de man sahel
après demain le cancer le sida le tiers
monde c'est jamais rentrés l'allemand
fait pas partie de ces vedettes du
show-business et dieu sait s'il y en a
en france qui sont branchés sur encours
mamans d'enfants
je suis souvent entrer là dedans je me
suis souvent
échappé du zoo n'est puisque l'important
dans toutes ces choses là c'est de
savoir où là les tables en argent et
comment par cet argent est là quand
personne ne peut vous répondre trop vite
s'en aller donc j'ai fait bon on va pas
on vient là dessus je suis aux restos du
coeur ne s'est pas nouveau parce que
simplement l'argent je sais où il va
immédiatement ce que je connais les gens
permis notamment bien sont très proches
et sa repens-toi pas chez moi c'est un
principe était enfin scandale un moment
en disant touche pas à ma chute par
exemple l'entente avait demandé de
s'occuper d'eux ne touche pas à mon pote
oui non parce que ça sonne non mais je
suis course juge bien qu'on peut pas
être contre voilà on investit veut pas
être contre sos racisme que je suis pour
et 60 mais je suis contre la naïveté je
suis contre sa part ça ça on ne peut pas
pour ramallah
comment ça se passe à la maison parce
que ta femme s'occupe des relations
publiques des restaurants du coeur non
parce que si j'écoutais ma femme on
ferait demain
je sais pas - disent que pour profite la
vivisection contre les toréadors qui
serait reversé aux restos du coeur il ya
des régimes bardot en passant par lan
qu'elle ne sait pas qu'elle ait
rencontré bon droit on est très très
loin
on ne dit pas qu'il faut freiner mais
comme on dit toujours sauvons les
baleines dans qu'ils ont les faut on va
faire un peu de promo un faux pas là
mais j'allais j'allais justement na waie
je trouve que j'ai fait un album fort le
dôme j'aurais qu'on en dise du clan va
en parler il s'appelle ici londres alors
que payet fantastique dans la musique et
de papadiamandis comme d'habitude les
qui sait se bat vaillamment 10 parce
qu'on le voit cela parce que on le voit
pas on le connaît pas il est agoraphobe
ou quoi on le voit jamais et ce type les
communs agoraphobe parce que c'est ma
patron prendre est-il encore après
simplement quelqu'un de discret et
l'instant est le compositeur turquie bon
je pense à vous mais sortir je sais pas
ce que ça veut dire si celle ci
attention on peut trouver le document
pierre a fait des dinars bienfaits des
disques et on peut trouver les documents
a répondu il travaille pour qui à part
toi ça va bien il vient de faire trois
même le duo de pas de charles niveau du
high tech puis a fait plein de choses ça
va c'est vrai que pierre treiber qui
passe sous un camion pick un seul coup
elle me fait aucun mort
je voudrais surtout pas passer sous un
camion ouais je ne souhaite pas non non
c'était marque mac
et puis alors les les les paroles sont
dénommées cloud deux mois n'aura eu
d'amour
ah bon c'est pas nouveau et ben hermans
et a dit un autre
tadic en soirée parce que quand je suis
dans la panade j'avais le beau risque
donc pas été dans la panade sur pas mal
de chansons voilà bon c'est vrai nom
mais beaubourg enfin j'veux du beau
beauvau
le singe d'avant boboul moi on se
connaît depuis des années et c'est vrai
qu'au bout il sait très bien
lorsque je l'appelle pour du travail en
lumière ont joué amicalement en dehors
de bain il sait très bien que je suis
mal que j'ai une idée que j'ai trouvé un
titre j'ai un milieu et une fin
le gagnant alors il fait sos sos annuler
sa venue au coeur fait pas mal je dirais
quoi d'autre là pour compléter la
promotion de cet album qui est en une
aire qu'elle me trouve fabuleux et il
faut l'acheter et que je vous souhaite
non je trouve que mon nom je passe le
content d'avoir pris cette album est
donc je me suis régalé ce point la
principale des choses bon alors il dit
je vais te faire une nouvelle interview
oui j'aime était à personne essuie les
plâtres ça s'appelle l'interview qu'a
calade des prêts rock voir par exemple
l'homme kempen de vigne
est ce que tu préfères lennon mccartney
toujours parfois les mêmes toujours
surprenant à ce que les jeunes lennon
c'est jean vincent backup neige c'est
une machine ouais l'insultent qui t'a
fait le plus mal
c'est pas grand aujourd'hui ah ouais
c'était quand
quelqu'un de nettement plus grand dans
un ascenseur et qu'ils voulaient me
casser la tête
peut-être même nom
le prix d'un ticket de métro toi tu sais
pas est ce que tu as déjà pensé tout
nous ont déjà passé quand la dernière
fois en chantant mais c'était quand
oh c'est souvent envie de te [ __ ] en
l'air à caen chante mal vos mails que je
pars pas quelqu'un de chambre peinture
la recette de la margarita
e
chacun la sienne les illacais non pas
une question de la mienne c'est une
question d'alcool l'asie bon si
quelqu'un veut mettre un peu plus de
rome tout le monde a le droit
qu'est ce qui était le plus
indispensable pour t'endormir par catane
la télévision montre tout le temps
quelle chance démission par ap
non soyons ce qu'il ya un ronron qu'est
produits par ceux des espèces de gros
blocs en avant
n'importe quelle pièce bien rondes
seront
sur avis ça évite tous ces ingrédients
qui font qu'on perd la mémoire
grâce à la télé on a trop c'est en
valais qui a tu le plus envie d'épater
dans la vie m'a plus hauts des bas mais
la lumière à quel signe tu reconnais
infailliblement la bêtise chez les
jambes
quel psy
un casting
la façon de se présenter je ne faut pas
de dire quoi par exemple patois faut pas
me dire tout simplement je suis machin
j'arrive de ouais parce que ça c'est une
école
saxon de test est-ce que tu laisserais
tapis pas mais là je ne serais pas allé
serait annonciateur d israël l école et
katia bault bien sûr ça va venir
non parce que ça c'est s'amuser ici on
va plus loin c'est plus grave ou si
c'est pour rire oui ok qu'est la
question en toutes celles que je t'ai
posée intel plus embarrassé ou de plus
inciter à mentir c'est quoi leur assez
de chaleur
oui parce que s'en va à 100 puisque on
est obligé de répondre rapidement et de
montrer enfin mur d'une chose rapidement
et tout est faux tout est faux parce que
ce que les gens qui ne se croit obligé
de penser ça sont déjà des gens terrassé
par d'autres et coupé mais ça c'est bien